If the ABO mRNA is the length of this string that you see here,
which is about the width of a single parking space in a parking lot. Then
ABO gene, the DNA sequence that the mRNA comes from, what actually have to be
about 17 times the distance away from me. All the way down there to Loren.
>> It's a really long way, guys.
>> Now, like most genes, just like the ABO mRNA
transcript, all other genes, almost all other
genes have some kind of intronic regions to
cut out. So the mRNA is much shorter than the DNA sequence that it comes from.
>> Matt, that was a long way. Seems like a waste of material though.
>> I know it sounds like a lot, but there's a
reason for this. That reason's pretty advanced though, there's a lot going
on with exons and introns, and it's kind of out of the
scope of our course. All I want you to know is that
if a gene has more than one exon, all those introns have to be
spliced out so that we can get the complete MRNA with just the exons.